hey guys it's gary vaynerchuk uh on
garyvaynerchuk.com
i haven't done one of these videos in a
long time so happy holidays
happy new year um really pumped for 2009
everybody's crying about the economy and
advertisers and all this and the bottom
line is you know what put your head down
and crush it there will be plenty
of opportunities in 2009 this is not the
great depression my friends go find
somebody old
talk to them it's not um
what i want to talk to you guys about
today um and i want to get really
into this and this has been you know the
situation of
reading my emails over the holidays i've
realized something i'm getting a lot of
attention i'm speaking at a lot of
places
um and i'm excited about that and if you
want me to speak in your conference or
anything like that just
send me a link to uh over here on the
side of the video um
and i've realized there's something
really interesting which is this
one shoe doesn't fit everybody
you understand ma it's kind of like wine
it's like you know
here's my shoe right can you fit in this
maybe you can maybe you can't but most
importantly
it's like wine right i like this wine
you don't
i like white castle burgers you don't so
if we've already established that
flavors
tastes styles art with music and all
that
sports teams i'm a jets fan you might
not be
if we've established that we have
different flavors why in the world
do we have to have one or two or five
systems
to do business that is a big problem
and i'm really tired of people asking me
this dear gary
can you give me five things i should do
to start my company what are three
tricks
that you did to build wine library what
are seven ways
you built up your twitter list what are
nine things i should do for my brand
here's what you should do you should
listen to one person
in the world yourself the intuition
listening
that we are doing as human beings on a
business level
is atrocious people look at stats
people look at other people's methods
and they try to do that
nothing would make me happier in the
world that if you never watched
another garyvaynerchuk.com video and you
listened
to yourself because i promise you i
don't listen to anybody
not a soul will i look at certain
metrics
absolutely but if my gut tells me that
those metrics are wrong
or there's a hole in those metrics then
there's a hole in those metrics
do you understand you know you know
exactly what you need to do to build
your business
or follow your passion or build your
family or your house what
you know what to do the problem is
you're not listening to yourself
you're listening to a million people and
you're not listening to yourself
the only thing you should be listening
to is yourself because nobody system
works
better than your own your system for you
is what works so if you need to wear a
tie to get a job
and that's not you then you don't need
to get that job
and if you work better from two in the
morning to six in the morning
than work then do you understand stop
trying to make other people's shoes fit
on your foot
execute what you believe in do not
listen
to anybody but yourself
we all wear very very different shoes
it's simple it's repackaged from the
things that i say before
but it needs to be said again because
way too many of you are reading your rss
and you're reading different blogs and
you're reading all these books
and you're going to all these
conferences and you're writing down all
these things
and you know what you're listening to
everybody else but yourself